[musique]
eww
En Corée, la quantité de plastique générée comme déchet dans le processus est d'environ 3 230 000 won.
Vous pouvez considérer cela comme 3 fois 200 000 mains.
Environ 45% des moutons qui se sont enfuis de boli appartiennent également à 1,45 million de races appelées Zomham.
Il a été séparé et déchargé dans une villa insulaire comme celle que vous avez vue aujourd'hui
entrez et
[musique]
lee
où
[musique]
Pouah
Au niveau central, la loi et le système sont améliorés,
Les gouvernements locaux le soutiennent administrativement, et les entreprises comme nous ont des valeurs environnementales
Rangi investit activement dans le 1er Like Me, et les consommateurs disent que cette entreprise est
Si vous êtes plus intéressé et consommez activement des produits recyclés Laden
Les bouteilles en plastique de notre pays seront complètement indépendantes.
Je m'inquiète de ce que j'ai préparé, c'est une excuse profonde et privée.
table à double vitesse